situé à guyancourt globe langue solution
est un organisme de formation
linguistique et propose des formations
en langues européennes comme l'anglais
ou vient l'allemand ou encore des
formations en langues rares comme le
chinois est destiné essentiellement aux
entreprises
laurent hénart bonjour à bonjour vous
êtes le gérant de globe langue solution
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler
des différentes formations que vous
proposez ici on cherche réellement à
accompagner donc des apprenants pour
qu'ils soient de plus en plus
performants dans leur travail et donc on
propose différentes solutions à ce titre
là que ce soit du présentiel donc du
face à face soit dans nos locaux soit en
entreprise également des solutions de
visio des solutions par téléphone on
accompagne également sur de la
traduction sur des préparations aux
entretiens de recrutement nous sommes en
général sur des programmes entre 40 et
60 heures qui se déroule sur l'année 1
sur des rythmes qui sont hebdomadaires
et sera peu près des modules 1h30 à 2h à
chacune des séances
votre société existe depuis 1994 est ce
que depuis cette date
vous avez vu justement une
nous demande de plus en plus forte
justement pour wii comme on le sait les
uns et les autres on est ouvert à la
mondialisation
donc aujourd'hui on peut pas faire
autrement que s'intéresser et de
communiquer avec avec des langues
étrangères
on a une fois de plus on développe aussi
de la formation interculturelle parce
qu'on considère que parler une langue
étrangère c'est bien mais comprendre
aussi l'interlocuteur auquel on va
s'adresser
quelle est sa culture quel est sont
d'habitude ses coutumes et tout ça vous
êtes ici si vous êtes chef d'entreprise
et vous voyagez beaucoup notamment à
travers la france et vous êtes souvent
ici sur paris voilà c'est dans la zone
vous avez connu globe langue solution
alors justement qu'est-ce qui vous plaît
dans cette formation c'est une formation
de 60 heures c'est bien c'est ça voilà
ce qui me plaît énormément c'est encore
une fois c'est cette flexibilité c'est
c'était écoute
des formateurs déjà à la base y'a
vraiment eu une analyse mes besoins
bien évidemment on a cette facilité pour
parler anglais pour se débrouiller au
quotidien néanmoins quand on commence à
rentrer dans les sujets un petit peu
complexe et qu'il faut négocier
c'est bien d'être accompagné par des
experts à la fois en amont et en aval
par le biais de débriefing là vous avez
un programme de 60 heures vous en êtes à
combien
là j'arrive à 40 heures à peu près
d'accord est-ce que vous avez déjà
atteindre votre objectif
pardon je suis assez perfectionniste
donc on n'atteint jamais jamais mais
disons qu'on va rire mes bras sont quand
même plus de sérénité
aujourd'hui globe langue solutions
compte une centaine de clients répartis
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines